and I think that the murder of Freddie
gray was just a powder keg to ignite
decade's worth of frustration and that's
what we saw last night if we willed I'm
appreciative and grateful to have the
family of Freddie gray in church on
today ladies and gentlemen cars were
damaged is regrettably poor glass was
broken it is absolutely shameful but how
in the world do you equate was this
damage to property of violence but you
do not equate with the police kill
innocent something is wrong because they
have a higher premium own property did
those on people dr. bright thank you for
still am talking late is a privilege
um what do you think about the nature of
the protest last night I think yesterday
not just last night yesterday was an
incredible outpouring some 4,000 people
showed up in marched I think what has
been lost is we've been protesting for
seven days and I've those seven days we
just had one regrettable unfortunate
incident what's next for the city of
Baltimore what's next for the Freddie
gray case I think now the whole world is
watching Baltimore we have any number of
issues that have to be addressed not
just in terms of policing but in terms
of policy and in terms of economic
development this young man was walking
in his own community at eight forty
eight in the morning but not walking to
a job because none are available many
people are comparing the protester
Ferguson are you see any similarities I
think it's completely different in so
much Baltimore has a black mayor a black
police commissioner a black head of the
City Council and so this is not in
Baltimore different from Ferguson it's
not a color issue it's a character issue
all of the people that were angry about
the baseball game being disrupted and
all the people that were angry about
police cars being damaged wow I think
they the moment that we're more
concerned about the destruction of
property than the destruction of
humanity is when we as a city or in the
wrong place
and so until you have public
acknowledgment of what actually happened
to him before he was picked up and
before he was put in that van I don't
think you're gonna see calm in the city